I was browsing the David Pakman show
reddit forum this morning at david
pakman.com slash reddit let's go through
some of the interesting posts on the
reddit discussion forum which i
encourage you to sign up for and
participate in first and foremost
there's a audience member on our reddit
who says we have had a great president
every century so far we are going to
have a great president this century as
well what are your thoughts and there's
a pretty interesting discussion going on
my immediate reaction when I saw that
Pat was yeah it's not going to be
trumped that's not going to be the great
president of the 21st century but could
it be in 20 98 or will it have been
President Obama I don't know who the
great president of the 21st century will
be so the 18th century had George
Washington the 19th century had Abraham
Lincoln the 20th century had Franklin
Delano Roosevelt the 21st century Donald
Trump I would say so far it's President
Obama yeah so far of the two that we've
had so far three all right we'll get
even Bill Clinton a little bit uh even
Bill Clinton oh yeah you're right yeah
no I completely was off in my head there
yeah well it's certainly not george w
bush that i can't say with certitude
okay also from our reddit discussion
forum human nature and recent evolution
a very detailed and thoughtful critique
of our recent discussion about whether
currently humans are shaped by society
or biology in other words have the
changes we've seen to human to humanity
over the last five to ten thousand years
can they be attributed to society and
culture or to some kind of physical
evolution a very very thoughtful comment
about that good conversation to
participate in also from the reddit
discussion forum a viewer asking is
there a spanish-language equivalent of
the david pakman show I've not seen one
so far now there have been suggestions
that I should start doing segments in
Spanish and the logistics of it are a
little bit complicated but I'm sort of
up for considering it but I think the
question is more is there an entire show
that is like the david pakman show in
spanish i there probably
is it's just not one that I'm familiar
with there there must be right well
especially cuz we deal with American
politics I don't think it would make too
much sense to do the show in another
language I think the question though is
this style show not necessarily it
doesn't have to be about American
politics necessarily with so many
spanish-speaking countries I'm sure
there are sort of like independent type
span shows in Spanish talking about
politics right I'll have to be on the
hunt for that yeah yeah absolutely in my
home country of Argentina I'm sure there
are many the ones I watch are mostly
older hosts but anyway we're starting to
get into the weeds here but there's a
discussion going on about that okay I
sort of jokingly talked about my
experience at a nightclub in Las Vegas
and going to a chainsmokers performance
and blah blah blah there were responses
on Reddit one of them being the one
that's up on the screen right now that
sort of call me out for not
understanding anything you know it's
like starting to be out of touch with
what is happening in popular culture and
blah blah blah what I think people don't
get Pat is sometimes the entire segment
is sort of sarcastic it's like yeah I
know that clubs are expensive and I know
about bottle service and blah blah blah
I sometimes just jokingly pretend to be
out of touch and don't worry I will soon
actually be out of touch with what's
going on but I don't think I'm yet out
of touch it's just the entire segment is
sort of a goof you know what I mean
that's great damage control but I think
the viewer is right here in that this
proves that you're not a millennial yeah
he says that my millennial credentials
were are in question okay so anyway
people complaining about that and then
lastly does anyone watch Infowars
and I've said before I do watch Alex
Jones and Infowars and I commented on
this thread a couple minutes at a time
but it is purely for entertainment value
I mean it is so interesting to me to
turn it on and to see people shilling
for you know male and female vitality
supplements and all sorts of
pseudoscience and unproven conspiracy
theories it is very entertaining I'm not
watching it to be informed about
anything you know every now and then I
tune in to Jim Baker's show but the
problem is it's just one long
infomercial every single day they're
always selling bonus buckets and
purified water everything else what show
was it that bought some of the bonus
buckets and
actually tried to cook the food and it
was a disaster oh I don't know I know
the drunken peasants have talked about
doing that uh I would do it like we
could order it but I think it's been
done so I don't know how fun it would be
if they didn't have it do they have
vegan fare I would hope so I mean if
you're talking about food that has to
last for 20 plus years yeah you think it
would have to be vegan right um I don't
know if it's dehydrated who knows what I
say what do I care about Jim Baker's
bonus buckets anyway we should look into
the food prep thing and see if we can do
something around it and even if we don't
eat them they can be used as a table
there's many different functions for
these bonus buck